speaking about involving other people
were you mad at and I don't really
understand we had JoJo siwa on were you
mad at JoJo you mad the were you mad at
us for for uh cuz we kind of messed up
you had you had her on you recorded
before we went live wow I love I love
you guys like knowing the tea um yeah so
I had I had Trisha pis on my podcast and
I love Trisha pis she is like you need
to have her on here she is she she's
just the best she's so iconic I love you
know she was on AGT was oh yes she was
she loved Howard Stern she was an AG yes
and she was fast talking right yes which
she always does I don't know if it's a
talent as much as it's just her and my I
it like feeds this part of my brain her
talking fast because I my ADHD I just I
love you don't yawn when you talk to her
oh Howe um and I had her on and you know
she's in that whole I don't I don't want
to say Scandal cuz it really is some
like real life but are you talking
about the
dck Binger stuff calling Ballinger
that's we talked to that's what we're
talking to Jojo about yeah and so I had
trishan and I just really like was
letting her know I feel like she hasn't
had a lot of real friends especially
female friends in this industry and I
was like I I really want to let you know
I'm here for you and I really don't like
that situation and I really have your
back and then a couple days after that
episode we cuz Brook and I are on tour
so we kind of have to stack our podcast
episodes like you know a couple months
in or weeks months whatever in advance
and so we have JoJo on and then I guess
a week later she comes on with you guys
your turnaround time beat hours and then
she just had a bunch of stuff to say
JoJo
that you know a lot of people including
myself didn't really abouten yeah and um
it it just like it looked so bad I think
because I think that you know having
JoJo on and being you know buddy buddy
with her after she kind of said some
stuff that Direct directly negates
Trisha um so yeah then your episode came
out my episode came out everyone kind of
thought I filmed it in real time so
everyone's like you just said you were
going to be a good friend to Trisha and
now you're having this person on and it
was it's all just internet just
even just talking about it I'm like what
the Trisha wasn't pissed though no
she wasn't at all um I texted Trisha and
I was like hey I filmed this episode
weeks ago I had no idea I probably a
wouldn't have had JoJo on or B at the
same time it's called canceled for a
reason B if I had her on I would have
just um asked her about it you know what
I mean I would have talked to her about
it and so you know that that's one of
the negative things that comes with you
know stacking episodes is the internet
is ever changing and the drama is ever
developing and based on timing the whole
narrative changes right it's like she
said this and now you're supporting that
well I wasn't supporting that because we
didn't hear this we didn't ask her about
yeah it hadn't happened and that is
what's crazy that's why I really I love
to do our episodes as current as
possible but obviously with Touring that
you know becomes difficult but yeah it
just became this whole thing that it
wasn't and I think JoJo is still just
like so young and I have I have empathy
for anyone who's you know navigating
their life in the public eye at a young
age and and I also think I don't know if
she was a supportive as much as she just
didn't want to say anything bad yeah I
guess I didn't I didn't really watch it
that's also my like problem is I will
sit here and I will can I just say
something the most important thing in a
podcast is doing homework doing
[Music]
homework